[Music]
okay I'm back I just click start
streaming and the phone just started
ringing
so that's slightly suspicious but I'm at
my ground this place I'm not gonna pick
it up just have to suffer through one or
two more rings or maybe it's done okay
so today is actually the yearly blitz
arena on me chess which starts in six
minutes and it's a six hour tournament
so I'm gonna play a lot of blitz today
but I'm gonna warm up first do some
tactics I actually try tempted this
problem maybe about a week ago and I
didn't finish it because like I did it
before a tournament and the tournament
started and I just forgot about it so
I'm gonna attempt to solve this it's
black to move I remember having a lot of
trouble with this one because I didn't
see how black survives after it can take
h7 Knight g5 all the lines just look bad
for black so I have five minutes to
solve this before the tournament and
then hopefully something good will
happen if anyone's in the chat let me
know if the stream looks okay if you can
hear and see me okay
using my mic and my my brand-new webcam
so so yeah anyway
Bishop take h7 the critical line is king
take h7 met g5 and then what to do with
the King Knight g5 we want to go back to
g8 but then there's queen h5 and this is
where I was stuck because it move like
rook da there's Queen h7 Queen h8 and
it's mate I play Bishop takes g5 h take
g5 and there's similar problems I guess
it's important to realize like the
resources that black has like all of the
potential defensive resources moves like
93 Czech Bishop before Chuck and Queen
85 check this Queen a5 move didn't
really come to mind initially
also this bishop before 15 come to mind
initially now I'm realizing that there's
a line after king take h7 Knight g5 came
back to g8 Queen h5 why is my trackpad
doing that okay King take a 795 King G a
queen h5 Bishop b4 check and when we
free the e7 square then we allow rook e8
and there's no Queen each side and Queen
h8 mates and the King can run to e7 and
that actually looks very fine for black
because black is pulling onto the piece
not getting mated and then there's
actually counter play against White's
King so I think once we see this idea
with Bishop to b4 I think then we can
safely take on each 7 not not worry too
much
so I'll move back then Bishop b4 check
nice okay that's a feel-good problem
well upload that took me a while to
solve we'll move on let's do one work
you might not finish this x1 will see
white to move after rook d6 it's equal
material some action happening both
nights I mean one of the first things I
realize is that there's a pin potential
pin on the C file a move like rook C one
looks pretty devastating like rook a c1
if black plays rook c6 then there's b4
I'm like what else does black do if ht8
we just take the Knights we defend our
own night and we like b4 so this is
looking very simple and then we just
take the knight ok that was surprisingly
easy
hello tamale or and hello to shark calm
day difficult names to pronounce we are
going to move on to one more problem two
minutes until the tournament starts
this position okay what's going on
material-wise White has a rook in three
pawns for a bishop in Knights but black
has some very scary looking attack like
all of the pieces can potentially
contribute the first move that comes to
mind is Queen take F 2 and then after
King take F to do some discovery check I
don't know if it leads to anything mmm
in the meantime White has some threats
okay what to do we take F to King take
up to I mean there's mighty five winning
the Queen doesn't help the Queen's I
have two can take up to 90 for King III
no more checks
can we take F 2 can take out to Knight
g4 but then just like King G 1 so I
don't think Queen take F 2 is a move so
probably make sense to search for other
candidate moves there is a fork in this
position Knight to d5 which could be
actually very simple we allow rotate g7
and then King h8 it's important that the
Queen defends this pawn and it's also
important to note when we play Knight e5
we're attacking there goes my arrows
what just happened
95 attacks are up the Queen and the f2
pawn so the most important threat is a
made into threat with Queen take F - oh
the term is starting let's just hope
this works
we take the rook okay awesome I'm gonna
join the tournament did I already join
the tournament oh no I missed the start
of the tournaments so I'll play some
random player had to do that one quickly
bouquet tournament starting some
questions from - shark I'm day Oh
Annika it's ok I'll try and remember
that
oh and we're playing a good player Abbi
chess master and a patron I'm gonna play
some normal openings I usually play the
budapest gambit and blitz but here I'll
just play solidly played Bishop e7 and
then go for Castle so very standard
Queens gambit declined and we're
entering a Carlsbad structure Carlsbad
structure is defined when black is
missing an e pawn and white is missing a
seat on oh this guy's also streaming
cool so maybe you guys can you can use
multitwitch multitwitch to watch both
streams at once I'm just still in theory
this plan with Knight f8 h e6 is very
typical bishop take f6 does it move but
it shouldn't be too challenging but
before he wants to mine already attack I
could play a 6 mm sometimes it's a bit
uncomfortable let's play a 6 he's gonna
play a 4 so the attack comes very
quickly
I have Bishop g4 here maybe I'll start
with that make him think what to do
about this Knights if he plays mighty -
it seems like black should attack on the
Kings side Oh his stream is in Russian
that's funny
ok that might be hard for non Russian
speakers to watch okay he plays mighty -
that was expected and now I would like
to do something maybe played Bishop e7
Bishop d6 and then like Queen h4 he'll
play b5 and maybe I just ignore it I
accept the bad pawn structure and I go
for peace activity like b5 Bishop d6 you
could trade on c6
we'll take a while before he can like
fully exploit the weaknesses and in the
meantime I just want to attack
maybe my g6 first may be somewhat risky
play in a long game I would feel a bit
uncomfortable here is black because
White has a very clear positional plan
but in a blitz game is probably more fun
to play for black with the King side
attack
this dude is very good at bullets okay
good to keep in mind he wants to trail
off LightSquared bishop switch I don't
think I have a choice unless I play
Bishop h5 but that runs into my g3
so I guess Queen g5 we forced to trade
and I'll have not H for coming and you
might play some Knight g3 move I might
go for this plan I just start start
being exuberant with my HP boy I
definitely don't want to trade Queens
let's play Queen g5 9 f4 is in the air
by the for probably he take I for so I'm
not quite h5 Queen to h5 doesn't quite
work so what to do here we not six Queen
h4 Queen h4 is tricky inch forward maybe
idea of Knight f4 could also just play
rook e7 but then queen h5 we trade don't
quite like that
there's Queen f6 mmm wait Queen h4
there's some tricks associated with this
like you can't play Knight at 5 because
the Knights pin to h2 pawn you can't
play Queen h5 who's Bishop to e3 I think
I might have some threat of just pushing
that pawn it's gonna be hard to keep up
with the chats but hello to the original
ice good to see you hello Miko's
suggesting rookie six
I didn't play rugby 6 because Queen
five he plays between f3
now rookie six looks uh looks like a
decent idea because we're got six ideas
um yeah I want to target the Queen
doubling up rooks on the e-file might
also be a fine option and he really
wants to find out of five but the
Knights just pin so maybe he would play
age three let's play rook f6 I'm gonna
try and manage my time I have a lot of
attackers but it's hard to break through
like his defenses are solid expecting
Queenie to here Queenie - maybe rook e8
Queen d1 okay I take on F to be unsound
yeah two ones out let's play let's move
try and keep building a pressure you
might win some pause on the Queen side
but if I can break through on the Kings
side it won't matter where b6 may be
coming I really want to take on f2 if I
take F to take up two Queen take H to
any place like 9 f1 hits the Queen Queen
h4 oh that's probably not enough
so what to do like night my that
favorite h6 some idea I have to move
quickly to take take 9 f1
okay I'm gonna play I don't want to play
nights 97 but I'm doing it because Rick
aged six looks sir looks somewhat strong
I'm holding c6 for the time being but
it's gonna come down to some time some
kind of time scramble hello to axe
villager Ben Feingold was praising my
streaming and computer skills oh that's
so nice
was it today's stream because I was
watching like about 20-30 minutes ago
but I don't think I was watching early
enough I'll have to go back and and find
the clip of that or if you could find a
clip of that that would be nice I'm glad
he's thinking here he plays at four can
I just do this he's gonna play Knight f4
i play Knight f5 I have some initiative
maybe g3 coming boo but g3 Knight a g3
maybe stuff is happening whoa he's just
ignoring everything but what's my threat
Bishop somewhere Waits and I take III
right then he has Queen e2 with a pin
and Bishop take that for I don't know
what's going on and there's no time to
think if it's uncomfortable I take that
for Queen e2 then maybe like rookie six
I really don't know what's going on
there's also a bishop they got four in
the air
so maybe Queen e2 bishop they got four
we trade rooks there's some annoying pin
and they take T five possibilities this
is getting really crazy but I just have
to use intuition
please Queen e1
which is a very good move probably
there's some fork possibilities and
that's a very good move
oh my God look I can take the pot okay I
didn't see that move I should have
played that quicker time is looking
worse he doesn't I take t5 here but then
we can trade oh there's some trick where
I take on each two and then take tic
now I take on each two in the end I
think oh that he takes with that I still
take on each - okay it's a time scramble
oh no he Forks on f6 no this is bad
don't take aged six
please don't you did it okay I'm down to
rook it's not what I wanted and I'm down
on time
this is really sad this is really sad
I'm gonna try and fight fighting
fighting but not really
oh that's so painful and he's still new
tricks
not really you should never resign with
her Brooke because sometimes you get
crazy rook but not in this case
okay good game that was really
unfortunate things got crazy I got low
on time I thought I had a tactic but I
miss king take f1 for some reason I only
looked at rook take f1 and Bishop take
h2 I would win this rook
it should take h2 there it was a
terrible move but maybe blacks just
worse here because a6 is weak and I'm
already it looks like I'm losing upon
maybe I have to play a five tough game
not
great starts awful tied for last place
okay we're gonna try and rebound it's
gonna be a lot of boats today playing a
slightly weaker player another Queen's
pawn opening maybe another Queens gambit
declined g3 okay a catalan will take on
c4 and then Bishop b4 check and then c5
they call this array Robson variation
this used to be like unknown right like
incredibly rare and then Ray raphson
started playing it and became a lot more
popular and it's one of these lines is
that like not too many like players will
study though I will admit I've never
seen Bishop f4 in this position doesn't
look that impressive my blacks up upon
here we could trade I have a 95 move I'm
gonna play 95 right over him because I'm
curious about this Bishop oh thanks for
the cheer dogs I appreciate that you
spelled ray Robson Ron Ron it's ray
Robson very famous US player I'm also
one of my good friends from from college
we're gonna take the bishop and then
black is still up upon oh thanks main
sequence for hosting with three viewers
and so much so much pressure now do I
take I could take still up upon oh hello
2x villager I may have sat down already
showed my dad the game we played oh well
that's nice I look like a genuine and
nice person it's probably just the
webcam like the nicer the webcam the
nicer I appear
okay he plays a 94 I might take d4 so
there's some issue developing the the
queenside for black so maybe there's
some cop compensation for whites
I could play a five in that Rookie six
or Queen h4 Queen h4 just looks like a
fun minute there's some idea is like
some Knight maneuver with me on each
seven there's also some ideas 85-84 rook
a 5 and then rook h5 these ideas take a
long time but at least they're long-term
plans of course he attacks my queen
let's play Queen f6 attack his pawn he
might play Knight d5 now rook D it will
come with tempo and then maybe in 97 oh
he just wants to win the pawn back and
if I play a move like be five years of
Knight g5 with a double attack on hsf
anemia h8 or H seven and eight so I
don't know if I can defend that pawn but
I'm probably okay losing it well I just
play nice u6 because the Queen's also
defending me too but he still wants to
win it wait so be 595 that's good for
whites mmm I could take the Knights and
he takes back with night when I play
Knight a5 let's try that
being a little bit greedy here or maybe
I play b5 actually looks like the nice
Center break because when the center
opens up now my bishop is happier can
develop normally and his King side is a
bit weak without a GP in kind of three
the top possibly in the future I was
about to say possibly potential and
possibly confined I also have ideas now
of reverting back to my original
checkmating idea on each two so he has
to be a little bit careful and my bishop
is now I can come in and do stuff like
it's usually a dream for a black man
this opening to trade off this Bishop
for this Bishop it's like when white
loses especially so many weaknesses
happen but he takes so Bishop f5 maybe
but then Queen c3 mmm I don't want to
trade let's do this next move hopefully
as Queen h4 oh thanks for the cheer wait
was that a cheer cheer one elastic hold
I'm not doing viewer challenges or
accepting viewer challenges because I'm
playing in the Year leaflets arena and
this is this is pretty rare it only
happens once a year h3 that's annoying I
should at 5:00 maybe Bishop f5 then
Queen c3 I don't want to trade this is
looking like a really ugly move but I'm
going to extreme measures not to trade
because this King side this week Bishop
f5 I do have to manage my time better
well start with Queen g5 hitting h3 or
pinning the bishop so threatening Bishop
to h3 I'm expecting king h2
or that something going move so 9f5 he
plays efore maybe I'm trying to be just
too ambitious
uh yeah his pieces are just better than
mine but 96 was probably not a good move
maybe I should have traded nights
earlier let's regroup complete
development rook c8 coming and there's
some initiative here actually like he
moves a rook rook see it happens
threatening b5 not that five will be a
tempo move sometimes then let's you just
want to look for a tempo moves if you
can attack something and improve at
peace you just want to do it quickly and
now there's some issue for a white
because this rook is tied down to the
Knights I don't know if he wants to move
to e4 but maybe it's almost like they
move Queen Queen B for the night
somewhere t6 okay I'll play Queen c7 hit
the knight this rook is very awkward I
want to punish it somehow 95 now it's
even more awkward a two's hanging I
think I'll go for the Queen trade
because then if he takes my route gets
active it doesn't take so maybe I go
pawn grounding take care so I'm up a
pawn now he might actually go for the
King side attack that'll be interesting
okay let's move the Queen back hitting
this and this another ruling let's look
for undefended pieces especially your
opponent's on different pieces that's
what leads to tactics
and he has to play ready for yeah any
tactics here I think I'll trade a pair
of Brooks I want to play 96 which would
remove the rook from defending the
Knights so I think we'll have to take
and then then he's probably in the
pickle I also have to watch time he
plays that well that hangs a rook I
think he saw my queen defending and now
I get to play my 96 move with more
material Queen is powerful from a 5 ok
GG well that feels good to have at least
one win let me use a emoticons the GG
emotes there we go
only subscribers can use that only
subscribers and me can use that so we've
moved up I've moved up 240 second place
with one win first place already has 16
points buzzer King every game maybe I
should beserk a few games if I want to
play higher rated players now it also
risk losing a lot of games
I'm knock oh this is the same guy I
played let's get revenged I was black
against him earlier it's nine lights
let's play a London this is my bread and
butter
opening always happy to see this
especially the setup I like to play c4
it's kind of a London light great
Queen's Indian whatever you call it
93 happens I actually forget what to do
here maybe Queen c2 I think the idea is
to just like play aggressive like Bishop
d3 in Castle queenside mmm you play c5
so the principled move is t5 but I don't
know if it works
so d5 tick tick might take Queenie for
mmm looks like it works I mean I don't
see anything wrong with it because
Queenie for happens and then if he takes
with Bishop I still have Queenie for in
the end so this sort of this is this
tactic I think allows white not - it was
a pod unless he wants to take with
Bishop and then play Knight c7 and then
trap my queen okay Queenie fourth he
could take my bishop or the night I mean
I I think White's winning material
unless I'm missing something terrible
because whenever he takes the bishop or
the night I take on b7 and I'm attacking
the rook and his night is still hanging
so I think he just blood burger but
maybe it's crazy enough where there's
some hidden resource I don't know if he
plays Knight c7 here then I take the
bishop for free okay yeah that's a good
sign he's thinking how are you in 246
place in playing a 2300 that's Ali chess
algorithm I think they're they're
algorithm tries to make it so if there's
player there if there's a player around
your level and around your place you'll
play them because they just try and find
like ferry matchups oh did you do your
1,000 followers stream no I I need to
like plan it ahead and I didn't see eye
five I guess that's a hidden resource I
was missing but I have Queen c4 okay
this is about to get really crazy 24
because he could play b5 this can't be
good for luck
because he has no ways to defend the
night in the night spinned B fives only
move now I think I have a pleasant
choice between Queen b3 and Queen take
be fine
if Queen b3 he'll probably play c4 when
I take on c4 with Bishop take take I
take on b7 actually in the end that
looks nice but then there's Queen e5
stuff
oh there's Queen a5 happening and a lot
of these lines like Queen b3 Queen 85 so
I should take care that should be
actually don't know if I'm winning
anything but at the very least I'll have
like a good positional game Eric Rosen
is deck scent decent maybe the ex is
next to the C on the keyboard for you
Eric well thanks for the clips I will
save these for later copy link address
paste copy link address paste
cool maybe I'll tweet them we'll see how
good they are Knight b6 I didn't see
that move but this is sort of what I was
talking about with like a good
positional game it's equal material but
he's committed it to f5 he wants to play
d5 though next move so maybe I play
Bishop c4 check oh he still plays d5
maybe rip d1 or Bishop c4 d 5f d 1 mm oh
then Knight takes you for wait what's
going on Queen take b7 that looks fun I
think this is one of the main points
when he takes your I teacher I think I'm
threatening this and this you could play
Knight c6 I guess but I'm also
threatening this so many threats
so knight c6 queen bee 385 rook d1
mmm oh he doesn't have her pH that's
nice he's 95 though okay it'll be
interesting like knight Knight a5 you'll
have to say 96 85 because the c4 Knight
is pinion so 95 oh no I'm getting a call
I'm going to call it back later
I'm just very popular so apologize for
that
ok Queen c2 I'm gonna castle this pawns
are weird like the fact that there's
pawns on c5 and f5 they give me some
nice central weaknesses to to massage as
yeah Sarah Sarah one would say yeah I
don't know what he's doing he plays g5
he's trying to justify like all these
plans of like f5 so it has some some
value I think I'd have to play Bishop g3
well he wants to play at for weight
whites by for traps and Bishop Bishop e5
t6 is he actually trapping the bishop
that would be pretty cruel and unusual
Bishop e5 d6 I guess I have rook d1 or
b3 okay let's start with Bishop e5 I
don't know what's happening
d6 b3 but then he takes with Knights so
I have to play rough do you want
he plays g4 at first which I forgot
about probably a good move
let's do beat three because it's the
only move I see I mean if he takes and
like I take them and the G file opens it
should be amazing for whites
I better be amazing for whites okay
let's take I take yeah I take here and
then a bishops attacked I have to move
it play Bishop f4
I unfollowed your channel a couple of
times because your streams were not too
good for me
but refile again because I can't help it
you are the best
I like I don't even know what that means
does that mean that I've improved or I
was just always the best and you
couldn't resist I don't know I also
don't know what's happening in this
position Queen a thought I was coming I
probably have to move my king I could
castle
well my knight would be pinned in two
directions what's going on if I take on
both I'm low on time - it's not let this
happen again let's play rooks you won
first
I'm kidding Thank You Casey eight nine
eight nine four following but I'm gonna
ignore the Chatham the follows for next
or the remainder of this game I can take
with check probably king of Finland and
[Music]
weight should be somewhat safe here
maybe 95 coming if you lets me play 95
but I'll be a nice move okay he doesn't
but now Bishop e5 will come if he plays
d5 I take on c4 this is completely
winning yeah cuz Bishop e5 old and in
mate okay that was nice that actually
resembled the first game we played where
it was a crazy position unclear what was
going on and why came out on top
somehow tactics just worked in the end
is there a way to subscribe through the
twitch I phone app probably but it might
be like a an icon button it won't say
subscribe but it will have like some
icon let's preserve this game and we are
going to play e4 because he's under 1600
and let's play some Scotch gambits
I like to decide my openings based on
the ratings of my opponents especially
for blitz g6 usually a passive move but
I guess it's playable if he takes on f3
I would have to take back the pony but
then I'm happy because I would have two
bishops I'd have some some G file action
in the meantime I'm probably gonna do
something like this or this Bishop c4 or
Bishop b5 I don't know
so indecisive let's play Bishop b5 it's
a pin may be threatening d 5 a 6 wait a
6 I can't play d5 let's imagine Bishop u
7 D 5 a 6
take-take-take mmm chess is complicated
maybe each three at some point like
provoke him to give me two bishops uh a6
there do i take take take take - I guess
I take and take there I gave him two
bishops but I should either win a pawn
or get a good position like if you take
some five I trade Queens and then with a
pot so probably a bishop take a3 is best
move but then it's just a better
position for whites because Rick d1 will
come with tempo and it's actually very
awkward like the Queen I didn't see
Bishop d6 maybe it's not too awkward
but positionally it should be good for
white
I'll just castle in the play against
these weak pods on the queenside maybe
start with b3 then like Knight a 4c for
because the c5 square is nice for
something ideally a pony oh your streams
were good as always but you stream
mostly when it was 3 ahem yeah I've
changed up the timing for my uh my
schedule I did I did have a survey at
some point I think the survey is still
accessible on my my twitch panels if you
click on feedback then you can find the
Google forum and I ask people when they
would prefer that I stream and one of
the answers was all the time and that
had the most the most votes which wasn't
really that helpful what we do here
maybe rip t3 there could be a massive
trade on c5 but I'm trying to just
improve the pieces actually now he can't
put a piece on c5 because there's a pin
or there would be a pin on the D file
maybe I'll play
I wanted to play Plan C for next take
take
then maybe triple up let's do it
I'm fixing his pawn structure but I want
to create this uh this Alekhine's gun on
the D file I don't know how strong it's
going to be though let's just put the
rook on d5 first hitting a6 which he
didn't see that's nice
and maybe I'm threatening Bishop takes
e5 because there's a pin this way and at
him this way that's also nice
first place I can't see the points
because my screen is too small and if I
expand the window then it'll mess up the
framing for the stream so all I know is
that I'm not in the top 13 places oh I'm
in 196 place okay so hopefully after
this game I'll move up my take I think I
can take that quickest way to win ooh I
can take that it's a continual Queen
sacrifice never up d8 coming next
wherever the Queen goes okay unless it
went to DISA or d6 okay back to Tremont
uh it would 90th place 91st place top
hundred how can you see tactic so fast
I've put in a lot of time to studying
chess I've put in probably over at
fifteen thousand hours between playing
and studying over the years so you need
experience to to be able to see things
quickly I keep moving down places let's
start the next game sooner rather than
later if possible first place 28 points
and catching up to the west beserk I'm
not gonna finish this whole tournament
but I at least want like someday
break-ins at the top ten will play
another London well play the Barry
attack I only recently learned that this
had a name the Barry attack I have no
idea who Barry is but I like the opening
it's pretty aggressive going for the
opposite side casting position and also
going for maybe some future h4 ideas you
plays a six he wants to play b5
um actually don't know what to do here
do I play e5 I can also play Bishop h6
let's do that because if we trade he
won't be able to castle and he castles
right away L get some early initiative
so now he v e5 Knight g4 Queen f4 let's
do it if he takes and I take back the D
file opens stuff is happening
one guy bead I am William Pasha with
this attack cool that's a strong attack
if blacks not prepared so now do I wanna
play Queen up for Queen g7 Queen g7 rook
F fades Castle queenside that looks
amazing
oh but then they take f2 so maybe you're
up to you one here wait what's going on
thank you ooh thank you downwards
something heavenward for subscribing I
appreciate that
let's play rough do you one but I wanted
to Castle King's Queen side but in this
case I'm holding on to f2 and I'm
creating the pin so he can't take on you
5 he fights to offend it anyway but now
he especially can't take on e5 down what
does that name downward is heavenward
confused okay and thank you Kevin for
following did you top a 1k subscribers
1k subscribers no I've topped 1,000
followers 1k 1k subscribers I think is a
bit more difficult but slowly but surely
it's from 94 Queen 85 check c3 Queen
take a - I have to move quicker let's
play h3 know I wanted to play h3 h3
would trap the Knights a
or it's just a random don't move that's
really unfortunate and now he's
threatening meat it should still be okay
it's to this so many noises going off at
once my meat tomorrow okay
age three would have just been like game
over that's annoying okay it's still
good for whites not the end of the world
I've done I've done worse mouse clicks
that was more of a trackpad slip I just
got so excited I I guess I extended my
finger too far anyway I can't undo the
past place that move I just want to
check the King now wait a minute that's
actually a good news or is it
I want to sack everything but maybe I
just taken play trip t2 I have to play
quickly forgot I deserved
I just want to move my pawn backwards so
unfortunate
now I'm looking for mating attacks oh
maybe I'll use my H pawn I'm so focused
on moving my pawn backwards I could move
it forward I don't know if it does
anything but let's do it thank you for
the follow something see on TV I already
forgot the name and thank you lever tons
RS I forgot you Castle queenside let's
take so many distractions I'm not going
to pick up the phone let's do Queen h7
my queens no longer useful
I'm g7 I want to bring it back someday
let's play Queen here this is a bad
position actually because this King safe
and my King isn't safe I have 23 seconds
left
I could still castle though right Bishop
e2 that's legal Oh II fives hanging oh
man this is bad but okay his rating is
low he's thinking I might have to sack a
piece at some point just to save my king
also threatening this it's Castle we
both Castle pretty late in the game
maybe I'm not losing a piece or maybe I
am I don't know he sevens attempt
okay we'll trade so I'm down upon could
be worse you seven still attacked I'm
guessing we'll trade bishops yeah and
then we'll were in some time some kind
of time scramble 19 seconds to a minutes
that's a fork but he just was a pawn he
could win another pawn few different
ways I just want to take on c6 though
how does he defend okay he doesn't
different keep checking and taking pawns
maybe Rex you Munchak let's keep taking
pawns pre move that he's getting low
enough on time where I can probably look
to flag him I had Queen c6 sir I have to
smooth that's nice
okay it should be an easy win from here
yeah I can breathe easy
I still regret not slipping there with
h4 h3 was such a nice fuel good mood ok
book a game that was the fights another
berserk in the bag on the streak to
berserks in the row and I'm I'm in the
top 50 that's cool
14 points first place has 40 points what
probably another Russian guy Shabbat
okay slowly but surely new game will
desert again anyone below mm I'll piss
work against and let's go for some
Sicilian
maybe I'll go for a dragon this game
dragon would be nice well accelerate it
if he lets me oh never mind no dragon
yeah Bishop e5 is popular these days
with this line I like to put them out of
me seven and then play a six and maybe
get the bishop pair he's doing weird
stuff
Oh oops I should have played 94 I
completely forgot forgot my crap well
now it's too late we'll play a six here
we'll trade a lot she had that 94
language Ben fun ok we'll trade him more
take Whitby pawn if he takes he doesn't
take ok let's play Queen c7 so now it
actually resembles like some kind of
open Sicilian time out of position o
crew 64 in the chat hello crew 64 I'm
guessing that's levy unless that's IT
guy could be IT guy
what do I do he's doing something I want
to do something let's play Bishop d6
it's a strange move but sometimes what
happens this black does this and this
and tries to get some kind of attack
what is he doing
Queen h5 guess it's playable play Bishop
e5 slightly strange position screamin h5
is actually kind of annoying because
he's attacking stuff and defending stuff
if I play g6 he plays Queen h6 mmm
take take take I'll just trade
everything and then castle will make it
positional maybe that's not the best
plan and realizing he has a strong a
very strong and annoying move here
hopefully he doesn't play I was scared
of e5 there he might still want to play
e5 and now at least I can do this and
get counter play actually I don't know
what b5 does apparently scared of it
it's like g6
it's an awkward position like this
Bishop wants to develop that it can't
develop this pawn can move from d7 so I
kind of just have to suffer Queen d8 and
I'm low on time again I figure out that
buzzards have to keep reminding myself
or people in the chat have to remind me
that I desserts that's the issue
I might just sack this pawn because I
want my bishop to be happy well he's
going for a 94 stuff that's gonna be
very unpleasant very unpleasant maybe I
go for f5 sacking a pawn or allowing
Knight f6 whatever he wants if he plays
my have six I probably take it this is a
bad position but at least things are
sort of defended to use my king of her
defense the king f7 then maybe d5 and if
I get D 5 and we trade Queens it's
actually not that bad for black oh I
didn't see that that was a good move
[ __ ] I'm just losing a queen and I have
30 37 seconds 36 seconds left
maybe he'll hang back rank mates maybe
maybe not maybe just please play even
Queen take me 5 wings for him well
that's sad
check they do call me the god of counter
play but I think that's gonna help in
this position he's defending back to
okay I'm gonna go for some von storm and
win f2 okay there's actually some
counter play now I have a past me pawn I
have a pawn you like it could be worse I
keep trying to play fast I'm happy with
the draw do you want to draw draw
actually no maybe I'll try and win this
is looking scary for a white
oh no I allowed Queen c3 but he didn't
see it that's good okay what is going on
here
f3 maybe I'm threatening Nathan one
please don't see it oh he didn't see it
oh that was so nice
gathered counter play redeemed
I was so pleasant yeah g5 such a sneaky
move such a weird mating idea oh man I
wanna like make a large print and frame
this on my wall Richy two mates
okay back to tournaments I continue the
streak I didn't deserve to Annette
I mean he didn't deserve to Annette as
well like based on how he played up a
queen but okay 20th place
wait his crew 64 playing is a big
question
oh he's working doesn't working involve
like teaching kids or maybe he's just
like teaching kids by showing them my
stream
do I want a berserk against this guy
what's his rating probably not
he's provisional and blitz hello sheesh
Maldor I like your name hello Chernobyl
Chernobyl pee pee okay
it's a London let's play c5 I have a new
idea in the London which I'm gonna try
in this game except he doesn't let me do
it
the idea is after he plays III but this
is this is just a different line I'll
play a six try and play normally and at
least this game I have more time it's a
double silent P what okay so Chernobyl
Chernobyl okay I have trouble
pronouncing stuff sometimes okay we'll
do this I already like blacks position
I have centered if he takes on d5 I take
back the problem it doesn't take on d5 I
might get an IQ P maybe I try and like
be aggressive let's play Queen here
Queenie v is actually a nice move
because it prepares 94 and rook c8 and
Bishop before and if I can annoy him
enough before he castles that would be
nice
a3 is probably a good move but 94 before
this should take before Pontiac before
Queen take before I like what I see
so he probably has to play rook c1
there's pressure
maybe rook C 196 and before is met with
my tape before this is my bread and
butter
I think I've said bread and butter too
many times when a London system occurs I
didn't say at this game though I mean
when I play those whites Queen c1 that's
a weird move go play knight c6 wait
knight c6 before what's going on there
take take it's risky okay I would have
to take with Queen oh then he can't
defend a knight okay
yeah so the line is before my take
before plenty before Queen take before
and there's no oh he has Bishop e5 but
okay he was scared now I can take if he
takes with Queen I have a nice move if
he takes with Polly I have good pawn
structure okay he takes with pawn
I'm good pawn structure my bishop still
needs to be improved yeah I play Brooke
e8 going for he five Oh Kuryakin losing
to Aronian what game was that oh that
was a really cool opening like d takes
e4 line I was surprised a row neonguy
and advantaged so quickly
but he was clearly well-prepared what
about the other games Wesley I know
already drew any other game that was
interesting ding Loretta increase shook
oh yeah the ding lorente grisha game
looked really interesting some really
old sacrifice line now I'm surprised
like there's a lot of people watching
for like a major event going on right
now I appreciate all the viewers and
people engaged with this stream a queen
bee won wow that's a fork it's a nice
move
Bravo what do I do
thank you decode three two one for the
follow he does leave c3 hang so maybe I
just take it ok when there's rook c1
what is this I don't know what's going
on here maybe I just play h6 and if you
take something yourself and I take on c3
it's a bit messy but if we make this
trade then I attack his Bishop so I keep
some initiative and then I also attack
the Knights I guess he has a risky one
here we trade more I take him D on d4 in
the end I guess it's important my bishop
defends this rook so there's no losing a
piece to very end you could also take
the Knights but then I take the bishop
thank you gents soul Jensen Lynch for
the follow and he's thinking which is
good so I mean it's a complex position
hopefully he just continues to think for
the next
two minutes that would be nice I'm not
sure what to calculate here like rook c1
let's say like rook AC one Queen take d3
rook takes d5 and I take t4 and that
one's a pawn for black I think
wait pawn to d4 quint 84 rooked 85 well
but then his bishops hanging on at for
deep calculations Kramnik is plus one
against Fabiano what game was that it
was some he 14 oh no it was oh it was
that like boring really boring Petroff
game how is he plus one man I thought
that was just gonna be a draw like it
looked really symmetrical maybe I should
have thought about this line a bit more
but like I didn't see anything here for
whites I think black is winning at least
up hellenic oh if he takes on see it i
have intermediate ninety two check so
now i take on d4 hitting this in this I
think yes to take on CAS I could
consider taking back with Bishop but
then he has Queen c6 hitting the rook
so I'll take here upon I'll consolidate
like very soon with Bishop e6 if he lets
me I have a funny idea play Queen here
if he takes on a seven with the bishop
it's made into actually he'll probably
take with the Queen but then they have
tea for this interesting position we'll
see what happens he's long time them so
yeah whatever happens should be good for
for me due to time I really want to make
the bishop move somehow
but how do I do that maybe a rook c4
first preparing d4 otherwise you would I
play Queen d4 and set up some blockade
hmm
let's do this od for Queen to h5 so
sneaky play rook c2 active rook
it's a weird position
I play rook a - I'm playing wreck a -
because I'm expecting Queen d4 and if he
plays Queen z4o Queen take f1 doesn't
work still but Queen taketh one works
now or no his Queen e1 that's annoying
I'm trying too hard to make like this
this dumb tactic work when in reality I
just have to play fast put the King on
each 7 and move fast take the pawn ok up
on now everything was defended mmm
that's annoying let's do this cocoon and
this we have 6 and rook c8
push the pawn okay good game
I'm not sure what happened in that game
and I think it was just a comfortable
win
for the most part another player another
provisional player
what's his actual arena
let's beserk I'll play quickly and I'll
constantly remind myself that I've
desert will play a Spanish he's playing
quickly and confidently let's play d4
kind of a pet line it's another one and
use like anti martial positions which I
think it's lesser-known
dr. Shackleton thanks for the follow
yeah I think d4 is like maybe the fourth
most popular mover fifth most popular
move and we're common is C 3 H 384 and
d3
with this line trying to remember
it's either a 5 or Bishop take f7 wait
just take f7 why can't I remember
anything I'm forgetting bishop
I know bishop take f7 was my idea but
how does it work take take my g5 ok I'll
play the e5
I just have to review this and then take
their Oh does he have c5 but then I have
Queen
efore at least so I'm not losing and I
was thinking too long but now I'll move
quicker I like my pawn on e5 of course
he wants to trade it maybe I completing
six and we both want to like redevelop
our pieces right I just have to develop
my queen side he wants to get this
mining bishop to better squares I like
this move east six though cuz if he
takes my Bishop become strong if he
doesn't take I mean I'll take on f7 he
could play top six
Astrix makes a knight and Bishop very
bad so he'll probably take or not I can
take care though and this is just
winning material now that I'd promote
right I mean he can take either a queen
but now I still have the Queen to play
with I'll be up a piece so he's going
for counter play now
so yeah things are under control I also
have some attack like we're both trying
to get an attack on the the keen side
now yeah he goes for Queen seven and
consolidates the problem for him is I
have an extra night my knight will come
in very quickly
and it's easier to attack when you have
more pieces and I'm not dangerously low
on time yet so that's also helpful maybe
Queen h3 someday Queen h3 why not trying
to provoke some some sort of weakness
like if he plays h6 I have between at
five so he'll probably play ooh let's
say you would probably play g6 Queen
athletic queen g8 okay let's be slightly
more subtle I'm just reading this or
this will just trade trade and play
quickly let me do it for more
simplifications you could win a pawn
back if he wants they should take h2
tactics
yeah just have to play quickly more
notifications wow so many streamers got
you a YouTube notification for someone
livestream let's do this I want to play
a bit of D for that that runs into
Bishop take h2 so I probably have to
start with some good like G 3 d 4 is
harmless it's interesting maybe I can do
this take take just lots of traits
pretty sure I can pre move or take you
six whoa complications what's going on
take take there first okay what is going
on I think we're just trading a lot I'm
still keeping the extra piece if he
moves his Bishop I'll play f4 or Bishop
c3 probably at 4 so we'll go into this
seems like he's a fast player let's do
this first and I'll try and meet him
with the rook and Knight oh I didn't
want to do that oops so that was a bad
move of pointless move I should say if
you plays a - I have nice seats you
that's nice
eight seconds should be enough hopefully
uh-oh that's scary that plant is very
scary but my plan is scarier three
seconds gosh this is bad this is really
bad
am I gonna flag no I flagged no oh man I
didn't fast enough got too comfortable
hello L ignorant a I was being ignorant
a with my time that game that's so sad
ouch what to do I was 19th in the
tournament
hello excise sparks thanks for watching
going back to the tournament oh that's
really sad lost my streak and I bezerk
that game he wasn't a cheater he was
just good at playing fast but his his
quality of play wasn't that impressive
what was right this guy if he's was
arguing me will play a London d6 Knight
c3 go into a perk h5 it's exuberance
this h5 if he plays h5 and casting
casting kingside is a bit more difficult
go in system benoni maybe e5
we file makes sense when the king is
still in the center
maybe d6 coming this could turn into a
very positional game wait if I take with
rookie is 98 might have to take the
bishop yeah this just might be equal I
was hoping for more there Bishop c7 I
don't see anything back right here
a4 maybe I'll play a four not the ideal
option but it's something maybe g3 now
g3 let's play Bishop e2 same idea okay
he wants to trade maybe I could throw in
this the counter-attack and his rook is
offered rook a seven looks forest and I
retreat my bishops are somewhat happy
and it looks like yeah I got the D file
that's nice let me trade more hmm
have to trade more I had the bishop pair
o he my pawn okay someone just just
subscribes I was feeling down but now
okay get some extra motivation here
thank you for whoever just subscribed
I'm gonna try and get kind of play I'm
losing a pawn but there's tricks
if he thinks upon is this move that was
a good move let's do this yeah this is
not ideal this is where we'll see that
the actual power of the two bishops I
want to make an outside passer like h4
h5 that's the plan he's playing well
he's using his pieces effectively let's
do this move he may have given me back
upon or not never mind
hmm I can take though there's some
tricks here
I'm Kim here please take on c3 okay he
sees the trick let's do that probably c4
next maybe I can win that pod and c7 or
uh b6 is weak maybe I'm winning two
pawns or three pawns am I gonna beat up
a pawn here that would be nice now we
get some pops of color Bishop ending I
think this is like objectively winning
actually I just can't let them blockade
like these types of positions you want
to advance your pawns on the light
squares oh this is difficult to win
since he has a fortress what do I do
Ike how do I even make progress I have
to pay me
man this is actually really annoying do
I mess that up or maybe it was just a
drama actively oh man I don't know what
I could have tried to prolong the game
that's so sad
maybe I just shouldn't have allowed that
in game but what else maybe fish an f1
better practical decision I mess up
somewhere here and maybe this is just a
draw or maybe do I have
perhaps I have that move to try and trap
the bishop
but then he plays King d6 I'm here and
games are tricky if I played c6 check he
just takes and he's happy just acted the
bishop for two plots that's unfortunate
why play blitz when candidates are going
on because this is yearly blitz it only
happens once a year
I guess candidates when we happen once a
year - but there's only one day of this
and like 14 days of candidates so oh
yeah how did Braden do he won so I'm on
a eight win streak eight game win streak
and 1636
congratulations Braden not bad okay I
guess I'll be zerk again I don't go for
aggression I'm trying to break into the
top something top-10 at least we'll play
as Danish scotch candidates stick with
Knights this is considered the stache
gambit see six slightly strange also
straightened Queen c7 what is he doing
I'm just gonna Castle he's not
developing anything this has gotta be
somewhat good for whites just gonna keep
developed
just play normally okay night bishop
take a seven doesn't work see five work
u5t v e6 do i want to go crazy wait
okay thanks for the followed salya I'm
just gonna play no I don't want to play
h3 that might help him what do I do here
rookie one maybe it's a good like it's a
good position I think for a white it's
just a matter of proceeding the best way
I'll be five okay I'll play h3 preceding
the best way I'm proceeding quickly
okay he's playing well to neutralize
guess I'll take or Queen e2 I'll take
and then I'll put my work in the center
rook d1 sure probably Queen g3 stopping
the bishop from developing applying some
pressure to the e5 pawn as well thank
you my teak underscore pl preciate the
follow explain it very quickly let's do
this I'm trying to do something here
maybe I'm threatening g3 somehow trap
the Knights or a force a knight to
retreat I don't know I mean I guess
Bishop c5 it's a bold move I take on a
seven taketake as if ESET him probably
doesn't work tried this and this if he
castles King side that would be nice
okay then bring the rook back I have to
move much quicker he is playing well
he's how long his pawn moved quickly
enough buying some Knight d5 stuff for
19 b5 okay this is nice now so I went
back I've won back the pawn I went back
another pawn at a key point he can't
castle because not ng6 would hang that
works the eights of threats expecting
rip d8 and I'll play a real easy one
that black stuff here
ah that's a sacrifice maybe I checked
first and then Bishop a4 and then I can
take
okay I still have to move quickly to win
I'll try and learn my lesson from last
game I'm gonna try and keep the attack
- lets force me it's France
yeah I mean - okay good game was there a
tactic with rook d7 Queen 87 Bishop they
are southern King take our seven Queen
to d7 wait white oh I think I know what
he's talking about in this earlier
position the problem like rook d7 Queens
87 Bishop take f7 the Queen could take
on a seven so I don't think there was a
time when that would be possible but
interesting idea okay back to the turn
mints I moved up okay so a twenty first
place but first place has almost 50
points that's rough okay you're gonna
keep fighting I think my internet is
better than yesterday I haven't had any
problems so far I think well I'm playing
someone higher rate than me
let's not beserk I'll play some huge IDI
maybe we'll go into a London what - I
play here I actually don't know what to
play in this position c3 it's a weird
move I could play I could play c5 I
guess he might take okay he's going into
a London wait what's the line c3 I think
this is a line it's just a matter of
trying to remember how I transpose now I
play Queen b6 this is actually a nice
equalizing line for black there's a nice
move here in ih5 which i think is the
best way to play he just allows me to
take I'm good with that
it's playing very quickly a lot of times
in the structure the queen actually goes
back to d8 to facilitate some some
cotton push you also play Bishop c2
which I can't really prevent so we'll
hold push pawns I have to take I didn't
have to take but I just want to push my
cons now there's some decision do I
ignore do I take do I push g5 take cake
take cake looks playable let's do it
looks interesting he does get the d4
square but I was thinking that like this
degree on for majority on the Queen side
should be fun to play with g7 doesn't do
anything let's play before first because
yeah when he puts is not in d4 you can't
use the attack d5 it's one of the key
points so now I can improve the Queen
he's gonna double up yeah just build up
pressure somehow ok he's building up
pressure too but there were kinda yet
people experimenting with Moo box do I
play b3 what do I do here maybe page six
I just want to see what he does it's
kind of a waiting game if he does that
then I would be very inclined to attack
him somehow between c5 first I want to
double up or I want to uh control the
e-file or maybe double up on e-file at
some point okay he moves the knight away
from D for attacks Appliance do this
the problem is when he moves in that
away from D for now there's pressure
against his pawns I might be ready to
play something like rook III I don't
think f4 is a great move he clearly
wants to attack me though I play brookie
4 here looking for if he takes with
Queen I'm happy if he plays g5 it gets
messy he wants to play g5 okay so I
could take and play rook III cos C 3 is
weak and g5 there's Bishop takes c3 I
think he's kind of over pushing here or
he has over pushed and now he's
suffering the consequences because he
can't defend c3 actually never mind he
had he had this move but now it should
be good somehow maybe bishop take h4
that's a pod worked you three is the
threats
I also just want to improve like rook e8
maybe Queen e7 White's King is not very
happy here
c3 is still weak to could also just
consider moving back and playing
positionally there if this guy's from
Texas maybe it's possible oh I don't
have a commands command sorry about that
please g5 he's going all out let's take
I have like social media commands so if
you'd like type in okay let me focus
first though I'll share the commands
later I take on f3 and then play rook e8
looks attractive but maybe that's too
much other candidate moves 27 Queen e7
take 2 okay Queenie 7 looks nice
he takes I have this if he takes here I
just take back I think things are under
control there's also some simple threat
of like this or this which he stalks hmm
maybe just rook e8 improve the rook
I think Brooke h1 it was a defensive
move so I don't think he had a threat so
weird position the bishops kind of stuck
here can I take the knight take that
looks good because if he takes with King
I think it's forcemeat so he'll probably
take on each for then I have Queen III
if that looks crushing it's crime like
really beating Fabiano that's crazy
that's really crazy at some point maybe
I'll pause a tournament just to look at
this the candidates games but okay this
position is exciting because white just
is running out of defenses or tickets
for Queen III so if King take f3 the
calculation is Queen III if he plays
King g4 there's just Queen g3 in between
take g5 so kingi - it's just it's just
queen g3 no matter but actually and then
there's meat next move so it was a
simple maiden 3 okay that's nice diapers
irk this game I don't think I desserts
or did I know four and a half hours left
of this tournaments and it's a long
tournament I'm already tired u18 that
was a nice game that was actually a
really instructive type the position I
want to go back and explain I think
maybe starting with this a5 move there's
actually a very famous game I can't
remember if it was Bhavana core
Capablanca I think was Botvinnik and he
had some like revolution I revolutionary
idea we were like he had some
structure with pawns on d5 and c5 and he
intentionally played c4 and it looks
like a very weakening move but it
resembles a structure where like this D
pawn is a backwards pawn and white has
this very nice square for the knight on
d4 and the argument I think it was it
was both Nick his argument was that yeah
you you give the nice square for the
knight on d4 but when the light lands on
d4 white has no play because it might
just block stuff and then when the
knight moves away it's not as effective
and d5 was always like easy to defend
and meanwhile I build up some pressure
on the Queen side
I think the way white Lawson scheme was
was just by over pushing on the Kings
side if he just waits like plays I moved
maybe h3 I wasn't sure what to do maybe
I had to go for some I would probably
still play queen c5 and then maybe some
eventual like rook e8 a4 or a3 stuff so
it would have been interesting anyway
back to tournaments yes I remember that
game oh it was Capablanca I should
probably like fine that game very
instructive game let's see Capablanca c4
the final move was Queen B - it was like
a nice tactic come on Queen B - oh yeah
okay if you google up Cobo block the
Queen B - it's the first result Oh sip
Bernstein I'll share a link in the chat
whoever wants to look at that game it's
a beautiful game it's like a beautiful
positional game and then it ends with
this amazing Queen B to move like
beautiful tactic
okay let's another provisional player
this is actual ratings okay we'll play
e4 I'll avoid the zerkin another game
with E 5 running out of openings I guess
I'll play pawns eonni I've been avoiding
kanjyani recently just because I've
played it so much
in the past but it's a fun opening
tonight not sure the link in the chat oh
I did share the like I've short-term
memory loss its way d5 and then take
okay we're following some main lines if
he takes on d5 is but should take g6
seems like he's somewhat booked here I
see four try and get some natural
developments maybe Queenie - it's
already scary like Knight g4 ideas for
black Queen e2 looks normal even Bishop
e3 maybe h3 first she don't what to do
here a good play Bishop g5 mr. g5 looks
like a safe move guess he has rook h5
hmm
okay I'll just complete developments if
she plays rook h5 I'll think and then
probably like retreat somewhere if he
trades Queens I'm happy going into some
positional game well I could also avoid
the Queen trade and play Queen f3
but then Bishop g4 Queen g3 hmm Oh Queen
f3 Queen e5 Bishop f4 and I don't want
to allow Queen e5 so I'll play rook wait
Rakhi one softens F to play rook a e1
okay more positional game more trades
happening hmm go play h3
subtle prophylactic move if you takes on
you - I'll take back with night maybe
there's an argument White has a very
small edge with more space and there's
plans of like a 3 B 4 I think well I'll
do I'll maneuver him up the bishop - 2 C
3 or it's just happier and then it
supports some B for expansion someone
beats Sam Copeland with Pazhani today
nice he was confused if you're confused
after 3 moves then you probably just
don't know the Ponzi on you so he could
move the rook to the e-file and he files
all only open file but there's no like
penetration squares like all these
squares are covered so he moves back now
I could play before right away let's do
it and I want to continue doing stuff it
may be rook yeah rook c1 future ideas of
c5 wait a minute can i play I could
trade everything oh he's attacking f2
hmm let's play Bishop even one Bishop e1
looks very passive but it is like
opening up c5 possibilities
I think I'm threatening to win a piece
with Bishop to g4 and then z5 so black
has to be careful he doesn't usually
want to play a move like a six or a c6
but you might have to a move like c6
I'll probably take on you four and then
play c5 does that just lose a piece take
take c5 maybe he'll get a few pawns
wait he takes with Brook in the text by
night I forgot about that but I have
Knight g3
okay I'll go into this using intuition I
think this works because we're taking
four night g3 with a double threat of
night 84 in c5 if Bishop to g4 to c5 are
the way if he takes their I have nineth
for attacking the bishop there's some
small complications though because my
bishop on e1 could hang in the very end
up in some lives and now that e 2 is
undefended like here even he could move
the rook back and c5 doesn't quite work
because my rook needs to the feminine
bishop to so we're just training ooh
wonder if Ben is watching just got an
email nevermind um okay rook t4 wait
earth t4i place he fine well he wants to
play rook t1 in the end what so I take
no I taken then play c5 that's trapping
it's trapping something I think this
looks good I had to take on f5 sooner
rather than later it because I wouldn't
want to run into rope t1 king of lineman
Bishop d3 check like in this slide
okay well the sign I'm just off a piece
okay let's be active that was nice
there's a nice build up before c5 and he
had F n b7 rip t1 King f1
let's be tricky and play a three please
take the pawn because he could play like
King g8 or king he eats so he really
wants to win the pawn so there's a rule
in these types of end games you're not
supposed to trade pawns like when you're
up a piece but wait a minute okay I'm
just gonna see what he does after this
is one legal move then I'm gonna move
back I want to see if he repeats the
rule is always repeats if he takes on a
three I went upon by taking here an
attack I can assume this now I'll move
back I want to keep the eighth point
because someday I might win all his
Queen side pawns let's do that use two
pawns for the bishop but the bishop
should be a pretty powerful piece okay
we'll just liquidate or not whoa
let's do this thank you aka a kl6 one
one for the follow so he's almost
getting there
but it's not going to work as being
somewhat resourceful let's play King 5 3
she has rook C - but then Bishop D for a
to work a three should be okay it's
gonna come down to time of course but is
a pawns under control
make one's kind of hard to win though or
maybe not maybe I just do this in this
Thank You BB wait I can't even pronounce
that name I'm not gonna try it but thank
you for the follow I can take that
oh but then f6 so tricky let's do this I
don't want to do that what do I do here
okay I'll do that then g4 and activate
the King yeah running the kings of the
the Queen side to pick up the pod I can
take that you forgot about the bishop
defending anyone okay good game top 20
19th place back on the streak
I think dr. Hannibal 13 the buck uh-oh
another London see what happens here
okay I'm gonna try this very new idea I
haven't really studied this too
extensively but 95 it's kind of a
surprising move and it's just a
different way of playing the London I
don't know how good it is but it seems
playable and it's just a matter of
getting white off if it's normal London
like comfort zone I'm pretty sure I
could take on b2 I'm not mistaken
wait 93
I was looking at this other day or do I
play Queen before check and then I'm
already forgetting I looked at this so
recently to remember Queen before check
this is not where I want to be like 93
is obviously a move I have to prepare
for in this line I play d6 maybe just d6
d6 is a safe move ok Queen before check
c3 Queen take me to 95 but my 9 and d5
defense e7 so it shouldn't be a huge
issue I just play a 6 in those lines
it's like the weird thing about this
position like White's trying to do
normal London ideas might be five movies
is very common to sack the b2 papa
but in this line because I defense e7 I
don't think it works the only reason I
found out about 95 is I saw in
protesting match I'm on Hamilton played
this again slim lay and just got crushed
as black but then I looked at the game I
looked at the make improvements from the
box I'd realize it's somewhat playable I
think it's great for blitz oh but if a
six he has rook b1 I want that and it
could just be a draw like really quickly
I want to draw either 96
wait and I take C three is like probably
the critical line
I take c3 Knight c7 King d8 probably
losing too much material but he has to
move the Queen somewhere he plays queen
c1 only move Queen before Queen d2 maybe
d6 I sac the exchange or I just take the
draw chess is so complicated take on d4
first book rook be ones coming very
quickly take on c3 Knight c7 King d8
Quincy one Queen before Queen d2 d6 no
I'm gonna be civilized take the draw
assuming he wants to draw maybe there's
some way for him to play for a win we'll
see what happens for anyone confused the
draw is this repetition so he's
repeating once drop okay let's actually
learn from that game oh did I just pause
oops I want to go to profile and then
ooh oh that's cool lights up when I'm
live let's go to the game I had some
prep in this I thought 93 I thought it
was Queen before I was just I basically
played that move from memory but
analysis board so let's learn something
because I'm sure he'd like he's never
seen this position before he just played
93 because it's like a typical idea but
does it actually work stockfish
oh and I take C 3 uh I forgot about that
move I should have considered that I
just thought coming to take beat to mmm
and then Queen G 2 so if I want to like
continue the game I guess this is a line
I have to go into we need you to 94
taketake Knight B 5 seems all forcing 96
I would play this seems like box
equalized specialty 3 we can take right
that's to take in d6 looks very nice for
black actually I mean blocks up upon
white has some compensation but there's
two bishops Bishop d7 is coming seems
relatively easy to play g6 and Bishop g7
[Music]
okay
I was interesting let's go back to the
tournament I am in I'm in 20th place
I still haven't broken into the top 10
and I don't have a streak anymore Joe
I'm on the buzzer call bizarre take a
risk the more game are the more
tournament points I get the higher rated
players I play so oh he lost oh that's
nice
I don't think I got the visiting points
did I know but that was nice of him just
too scared of me okay 14th place
probably one more win and then I'll
break into top-10 maybe this game I
don't want to bezerk let's play a London
a couple London's in a row Bishop f4 see
his prep g6 we're gonna transpose into a
berry attack with Knight c3
or I complete each for immediately play
next entry first the sticking with my
prep if he castles I play h5 if he plays
ht5 himself I play 903 the sign I
thought was very fine for whites so with
the bishop on g4 like he's basically
provoked to trade maybe I take with
Knights get the knight to the kingside
put the pawn on c3 it's very common in
the slide like the knight on c3 isn't
that useful and it goes to e2 so white
can play c3 I'll take with equal on
maybe f3 f3 I could play my G 3 D it's
finite g3 first thanks for the follow
Persian banger thanks do I do this or
this or this
okay just keep moving back and forth
okay Queenie to probably visually it
looks the most natural C files half open
now I'm not sure like does white one the
Castle queenside or Kings I probably
Kings side because he just played rook
c8 I feel strange with the pot on each
for but okay the King's safe I might
still try and get some King side attack
it might be difficult I I have a lot of
pieces on the kingside but it's hard to
find some some weaknesses just gonna
play normal moves maybe Bishop g5 g5 is
kind of the one-week square in the
turret and Black's territory you plays
a5 interesting I play for let's play for
position on this because it opens up
some opportunity for Queen B 5 and then
if we trade Queens the a file opens I'm
happy so this might be the type of
position I play on both sides of the
board I completely forgot there's
another resource there was another
resource might take f7 but not anymore
hey rook c6 still tempted to play Queen
b5
there's also Queen f3 what you might
lose up on em have to move quickly I
just want to play a normal improving
move and play f3 actually do I wanna
play up three restrict some Knights
looks a bit weakening well I have a
really funny idea okay I'm gonna play f3
I was hazard in this way of three
because I want my knight on f3 but now
I'm realizing I have this funny maneuver
Knight h19 f2 93 I have to be careful
maybe start with Queen d2 oh there's
this other two I might have to play some
preparatory moose see how dangerous it
gets
but I really want my knight on d3 2 here
and h1 is actually the quickest way to
get there
and then when I go to f2 I stop the
payment so that's nice
Bishop h6 we didn't see - I guess it
looks like strange play yeah I want to
lose a piece let's do wait a minute I
have to take Tate I should be three
scary in some situations am i doing here
miss bishop g3 my king will be safe on
h2 and there might be some trade on the
e-file
it's so weird position and I wasn't h1
is about to be a good piece on d3 and
he's thinking which is good there's even
some potential for like 9 f29 h3 Knight
g5 well it's very common with this
structure usually the best work from the
night is his d3 because it complements
the pawns like so well but he's playing
very thematically like he wants to open
the center before I could get my pieces
in play but his pawn is pinned and also
attacked three times now because I broke
the pin with the Knights so lots of
tension I can probably went up on that
looks like a free party has Bishop e3
maybe Oh
chess is complicated again
take-take-take with bishop but then f6
wait what's going on take with pawn
Bishop e3 maybe just f4 ok I'll go for
that
Bishop III looks annoying but I don't
think it should do too much king h2
immediately he takes on e5 okay I'll
play a four first I just want to play
King H to consolidate he's continually
applying pressure
I play f5 f5 looks amazing
that looks devastating for black is
everything's about to fall apart now I
take here he's hacking the exchange I
think I can take take and then King f1
probably there's some counter play but I
like White's chances cuz his King is
also if he probably next when lose Queen
e2 heading missing this and I just don't
see too many attacking resources for him
Oh though he has one move whoa he could
have like liquidated into a King pawn
ending that would have been really
interesting
he could have taking on an f2 twice and
then played 93 but maybe he missed it if
he saw it he should have gone for it
Oh do I take probably not I have to move
my nights or g3 g3 looks nice restrict
his nights mainly preventing that F for
giving my King a square on g2 I'll be
patient
slowly but surely 93 hold still might
happen or maybe not 93 still we can
trade what ok we'll trade more ok nice
game I just want to quickly look at that
because he had a move which would have
been maybe just drawing I don't know in
this position if he takes on f 2 I guess
I could take on e5 first but maybe it's
similar take take take 93 I thought this
might happen it's probably Josh
but all three results still possible the
stock fish have any new thoughts
Oh whites better why is white better
kini to king of five-o maybe some looks
long like White has more tempie to waste
with b3 and g3 so oh there's some long
option where white will eventually play
King f3 and G fork yeah this is actually
winning for whites because when g4 comes
and these pawns get traded this is an
outside passed pawn so he could play f5
but then I assume just we need to go
after this pod
being f6 oh it's just looks long again
okay
eventually there's infiltration okay
interesting let's go back to the
tournament's
not sure if I would have found all of
that but yeah I had good chances to win
14th place 39 points I'm catching up to
the leader this guy on a very hot streak
I'm gonna berserk when I can just from
now on any player below
2,100 multiply a dragon why not fun
opening especially the accelerator
dragon wait a minute bishop
you didn't play Bishop b3 is or some
tactic here can i play Queen b6 I forget
the line I only know one idea here I'm
just gonna play the one idea I know what
does berserk do maybe someone in the
chat can answer that - meadow one one
one ik so no it was metallic d5 he's
confusing me with this strange move
order he's six maybe I'm gonna still
play e6 that's the idea of rookie eights
because when I play d5 the bishop on e3
is a bit softened so I get the center
opens up my rook is happy I actually
don't know how good this is this could
maybe be bad in this line I don't know I
have to move quicker just have to move
much quicker but what do I do maybe 95
that a 5 looks nice I just want to get
the bishop here
Bishop e6 okay
it's a playable position not yet below a
minute which is nice
rook c8 come in and maybe some hogs form
I'll consider asan a5 b5 type moves
maybe a5 first a5 woah hang upon take so
many lines to consider um I have to take
think maybe he just went upon but I
don't know maybe I'll get compensation
cuz now if he wants to win the pawn he
has to take on oh he takes on f6 I take
on b3 and that's trouble for him
I was about to pre move Bishop to get
six this is a nice intermezzo this is
bishops hanging and this is hanging and
a move like bishop c3 I mean I'm up a
piece currently so I don't think he's
gonna survive this
okay well that was a nice finish I might
go back later to look at that opening
but I broke into the top ten I'm gonna
try and work my way up to first the
competition will probably get a bit
steeper we'll see ya
this is a guy oh I'm playing the guy in
first place that's cool we'll play a
London Kramnik is messing that's too bad
gromek usually doesn't mess up but chess
is tough okay I'm playing this might be
d2 line I'll go for a c3 this is one of
the most main lines in the London this
should be v is a first secondary move
97th is not a good move because of e4
we're actually following a Carlson game
Carlson just completely crushed his
opponent Carlson Bosio Chooch mm
something I can take he writes just have
to remember these lines and then I take
care of whites winning at least upon I
think this is still the Carlson game now
Carlson took on each three with the Hawn
I actually found a cool improvement
where we take the Queen first it will
probably transpose that I'm giving the
him the option of taking on f2 which he
doesn't do so now there we're back in
the the Carlson game Carlson's opponent
played f5 and then Carlson played c6
it's nice to win a game and you don't
have to really think you just recall the
moves because opponent played on somehow
I think his opponent played 95 but it's
just a terrible position after a bishop
takes e5 and rook to you want yeah I
forget what year but it was a relatively
recent game
do you mind yeah this is just like
whites up a pond and it's good night
versus bad bishop and the seasick spawn
is pretty menacing yeah I think I knew
he was gonna stumble into the Sinai with
a desert but okay this is nice
how do you just remember these games um
I mean this particular game I've studied
many times and I've had it in a rapid
tournaments like over the board
tournaments so I've had many
opportunities to just repeat it another
trick for remembering these games is
just understanding each move so I've
made an effort to like identify the
purpose with each move and just like
know the nuances he wanted to win the c6
pawn but no success there I'll play King
c2 and then rep d1 and the Carlsen game
is a reason why I started playing Bishop
b5 in the opening rather than Bishop d3
so now like beef for b5 ideas even c7
could be a threat potentially but this
is torture for black plays rook c8 so
now probably before if he goes for d5
I'd probably go for c5 and this Bishop
is forever depressed on e6 you remember
these games memory is utilized for it
yeah memory is important for remembering
things
yeah just for anyone who wants to see
the Carlson game I actually I gave a
lecture at the st. Louis chess club like
a part two to the the London video that
I did
and they recorded it but they never like
published the the part - on it and part
two is where I showed the Carlson game
so it will just go to analysis board and
then it should be easy to find just like
opening a book and then I mean I have
I've had this exact same line like so
many times Oh Thank You Daniel roads
1984 for subbing actually appreciate
that yeah I'll just share a link in the
chat I guess and for anyone like who has
watched the sixty minutes Carlson
documentary like Carlson knows like I
think around 10,000 games by memory
which I mean it's helpful to you know so
many games just so you can reference
like strong ideas have been played in
the past
oh it's 2016 yeah so not too long ago
[Music]
yeah Queen take T it is it's funny it's
giving black the chance to play Bishop
take F 2 and this would this would run
into c6 which i think is just winning
for whites because my t5 rook d1 it's
very similar so yeah what happened that
game how long did we follow the game so
c6 was played like if I take take
rippity 1 so this was all the Carlson
game Bishop a 695 was this exactly oh
wait no I'm in the wrong game okay but
we played through the same thing
oh so Bishop b5 was a novelty okay
that's funny
well it's nice to play like the first 20
moves exactly the same as Carlsen let's
go back to the tournament try and
not waste too much time 48 points eighth
place he's gonna get some juice real
quick let's do another London little
dessert this game feeling good with the
London today
fabbi and all caps what's going on with
fabbi is he who is he playing this
playing crime neck race is he surviving
[Music]
what wait what this is just like slush
it's not liquid
oh man to wait for it to melt or
something do I play okay I'll play Queen
b3 I like to call this the copycat
variation of the London like you cop or
black hotties whites then white goes for
the early c4 Queen b3 and I forgot I've
is Erick I've already used 30 seconds
which is not acceptable given I'm still
pretty much an opening prep I'll play
Knight c3 D actually I'll probably play
b4 first sometimes it's a question where
it doesn't matter velop - thanks for the
cheer from exei sparks 150 bits for
memory appreciate that yeah I mean we'll
start with before because sometimes the
knight wants to move to a5 like so and
b7 sometimes a long long time weakness
9h five so early let's not give him the
bishop pair Bishop c7 is a weird move
but yeah it takes them a couple tempi to
attack it and h3 is very useful because
I have a retreat square I could also
play g4 here I'll play Bishop h2 and
then I'll start doing stuff and it's a
very positional game I'm very happy to
keep this Bishop because he doesn't have
moves like rook c7 and rook b8 to the
feminists on g6 so I'm just gonna attack
the pawn then maybe just win it right
away
mmm this is very hard to drink it's
supposed to be like really healthy kill
Carol is the main ingredients grapes
apple banana pineapple pear juice orange
juice coconut water cayenne pepper and
chia it sounds healthy
'if I've it's other free pod looks like
multiple fruit ones take ok he's trying
to make it complicated I play up three
and just trap the Knights he has my g5
wait let's calculate when I take b7 okay
I'm only calculating one move I take
these seven wins upon and rook b8 I can
take money 6 take on these six anyway
I'm just winning all his pawns now this
is a good few games for the London 96 is
coming maybe maybe not right away
wait 96 oh he can why was I thinking he
could take the Knights but I have to
defend this pawn so maybe I for
and then we trade or we don't trade I'm
just gonna castle this Bishop is
slightly sad but it's done its job
someday it will re-enter the game f6 I
can take this Bishop is also sad oops
let's do this Bishop d7 is playable and
then that d4 and c6 is weak so weird
pawn structure whites up three pawns
though I haven't lost a single pawn I'm
gonna try and win this game without
losing a single pot hey I won the game
without losing a single pawn that's nice
yeah that was another like feel good
London game a lot of idea it's like I've
seen before like this whole first of all
this h3 Bishop h2 and then this like 93
95 and then he just tried to make a mess
of it
it didn't work okay back to tournament
I moved from eighth place to seventh
place slowly but surely I'm only eight
eight points behind the leader and I
started about an hour late so oh no I
just oh my gosh okay let me be right
back I I was shaking the juice with no
lid on I got distracted let me play my
first move and gosh can the game to
start because I have to like this is
this is embarrassing
I could pause what do I do here I'm
gonna play c6 and then I'll return
wait this is a guy in first place I need
to beat him again oh this is really
annoying I'll be right back
I just got juice all over me this juice
is a curse Thank You Daniel Rhodes for
cheering 100 100 bits appreciate that
for the spillage that's nice yeah I'll
be right back d5 Castle
okay I've learned my lesson not to shake
juice when it's open what do I do here
do I play I guess I play d5 I just got
so excited from winning that game I just
shook the juice prematurely at least
he's thinking maybe was thinking because
I took such a long think I wonder maybe
he's watching this stream too because
that's possible b6 is a reasonable move
ideas of Bishop a6 trading good bishop
trading bad bishop for good bishop the
Knights a bit awkward but what to do
maybe six this Knight wants to come to
d6 and then eventually four I'll play
rook c8 first no notic c8 first mattify
first let's try and move quickly Queen
d7 and 95 okay I'll play 96 I think they
call it they call this a capablanca
Knight 996 pawn on d5 95 makes sense I
want to play rook c8 wait is a slagging
I connected I'm connected I'm sorry if
there is lag saw the red box I want to
play rook c8 the think we need for a bit
annoying
so maybe I'll put the Queen on b7 and
then we'll see it and then things are
defended this is so weird it feels like
I'm eating juice like it's not liquid
form it's so thick but at least it's
healthy I'm not sure what White's doing
here because I was gonna say that if the
knight moves I have 94 guess he wants to
play like Bishop b4 but I'm gonna try
and challenge the C file let's try it
with her c8 mmm do I take
that's my bad night but that's also his
bad Bishop take take take mm-hmm let's
keep the tension for a bit longer it was
like most of White's pawns are in dark
squares and he's a bit awkward on the
Queen side so I'd want to leave him
being awkward
nice e3 looks reasonable all retreats I
might not be playing the most accurately
but I'm trying to keep the tension make
him think night b5 yeah I'll move back
we might repeat and then if I want to
play for a win I have to do something
else
hmm giving some lift for the bishop its
reposition the Knights maybe a six is
coming maybe you can see six is coming
not entirely sure he really wants to
invade the square which I might have to
although this could leave this could
lead to like massive trades but okay
stuff will happen I don't think I'm
losing anything
oh maybe I'm losing the a pawn but if he
wants to take the a pawn I should get
countered play a queen c4
Queen e2 ideas you would like to play
Queen d3 but he's tied down to the
bishop currently oh and it's we need to
Queen d3 I take on b2 also threatening
Queen f2 oh there's a funny line but you
didn't walk into it okay I'll play this
if you play Queen d3 Queen f2 Queen
ZigBee 2 eyes for any me a triple fork
which you wouldn't be able to stop here
I'm threatening the very simple work c2
and then I don't know how you defense
yes to put something on c3 like Knight
c3 but then I have Knight d2 wait no if
he moves anything to see through that
Queen take III you could just be in like
huge trouble like this just might be
winning for black what is he doing here
Burke c2 is coming and he can't play
Bishop c3 or Knight c3
that turns bad really quickly I think he
just got too greedy like he took on a
seven it's bad for him
chest 24 clocks are off it's hard to get
clock times accurate with a live
broadcast especially if you're not the
one who's like organizing the
tournaments and stuff to the organizers
to feed correct information but there's
like video footage that will hopefully
be accurate yeah let me okay this guy's
just thinking let's open candidates in a
new tab chest bomb let's check out this
Kramnik game and I'm not going to show
the tab on screen cuz well I have I like
a fear it--not because its broadcast for
a different site but let's check out
kramnik whoa what is going on here I'm
not like using engine evaluation I just
see the current position yeah take on
you three this is force mate oh I would
have liked to smother meet him but okay
that was nice
back to tournament moved up to fifth
place working my way closer seven points
behind first hchc good luck let's beserk
on the verge of breaking 2,400 Queen
take III was check X I sparks yeah we'll
play a Ponzi on you this game
this is one of the probably the most
made mine he could take either con you
could take on d4 or take on e4 Knight BA
I actually had a tournament game in the
slime against priyadarshan con upon them
I remember looking the sign afterwards I
forget I forget what I looked at I know
there was a more challenging move than
9.3 maybe Queenie - we need to or was a
queen a forecheck wait a minute Queenie
forecheck just wins a piece friends like
this guidance play this wait maybe
Knight f6 yet to play first and then d6
Queenie for Chuck is like a common
tactic in the slide he's trying to save
the piece but is he succeeding I can
take takes with pong and I take with
night and I have so many threats on the
diagonal I'm against this Knight some
move like Knights 'if I don't know let
me not say anything in case he's
watching he resigns I was actually
scared of knights e5 analysis board nice
e5 what's going on I take to you oh I
efficient be fine I check okay and
whites whites up upon and doing very
well
okay probably not a reason to resign but
that's nice
quick buzzer Quinn second place ooh this
is getting serious is V chess or is are
they not detecting the stream because it
wasn't showing that I was streaming in
the tournament area
I'm just curious now it shows I'm
streaming here okay that's weird
Chesky feel like I play them yeah I
played them before I won before forget
what happened in the opening that game
let's play d5 hmm maybe I should have
desert
we're playing another Ray Robson
variation with c5 it's a fun sideline he
takes early and I can take back when
usually what happens we both castle
he plays Queen e4 he wins back the pond
and then I have a secret pact move so
hopefully we'll get it we'll get into
secret prep both Queen c2 and Queen
eight for it should meet to my secrets
mmm maybe he's scared Knight c3 has a
new move but it's hard now for a white
to win the pawn maybe I play a six so
then he wants to play Knight 195 Queen
c7 let's play a six first there's many
ideas with like Queen c7 where I defend
the pawn with tactics if he takes I had
bishop take f2 mmm maybe he's getting
some counter play hopefully not too much
my g4 could be a threat rook T it's
coming the main drawback for black is
this Queen side development
so let's develop
hello Anton chess fan how's it going
oh I'll share the secret after the game
if you guys remind me so I'll probably
forget Bishop g5 is a good move I want
to play Knight g4 but that hangs a piece
point 97 and E 5 is actually a really
nice square for the knight where it
can't be removed that targets a square
and maybe in the future I'll have my g4
also blockades upon which basically
kills the bishop but I can play b5
Bishop d7 and be happy life is good he's
thinking I forgot to berserk
that's 5500 arch-nemesis okay we'll play
this I don't think he has any threats I
guess it's about making threats of my
own maybe I play 93 93 rook moves Queen
d4 check looks fun
maybe the Ottoman that comes to e5 like
we both want to attack on the Kings side
but I think black is getting the earlier
initiative now there's a line Queen d4
check King f1 and I've pinned it myself
so Queen c5 check King F 195 I don't
know guess we'll do that if he plays
King off on there should be some
something fun somewhere someday maybe
Bishop d7 Bishop b5 whoa I didn't see
that move that was a good move
I just losing material Queen III 23
rookie 2
okay I got careless that's unfortunate I
mean I'm gonna have a compensation but
this is not what I wanted Oh cuz I lose
each seven I'll have to fight it's
really not what I wanted
mm such a good position - I just forgot
about Bishop e7 so maybe queen d4 is a
veteran move there
at least my Knights are good you can win
age seven or he can do that I don't
really understand I'm gonna move do this
oh he wants to check me me 28 okay now I
understand it's so I can play queen 85
when a five should be okay
and he's gonna play b4 but then they
take before okay I think he's giving me
time cuz now at some point I'll have to
move his knight back I'll play Bishop d7
I mean I'm hopefully gonna get counter
play and if he takes on each seven I
have this I think nice move by g6 you're
at Bishop d7 so now my queen is not tied
down to d8 his nice attacked twice
expecting Knight c3 and guess improve
the bishop bishop c6 okay oh now I can't
play my G 6 mm play rip to Yeats and
then he checks in witness g7 oops she
winning g7 regardless
I want to lose this game this is really
annoying I have to lose g7 what else to
do here
things are stuck like b5 b5 actually
seems like a decent try it defends and
it tries to initiate some attack and
this Queen alone cannot kill me it's
just a matter of keeping his other
pieces out the problem is he's already
up the exchange and he's gonna win a
pawn here but if he goes for Queen eh a
king e7 Queen take g7 I'd be for in the
end that's scary
it is scary I was scared of that do I
take my bishop well take the pawn his
major problems here maybe King d6
actually don't see it clear like
follow-up for a whites because this is
defended this is defended this is
defended this is attacked which I
probably can't take it also play Queen
e7 play Queen d8 trade Queens I mean
usually you don't want to trade Queens
in these situations but got to do what
you got to do there's still counter play
but there's pins everywhere who's
getting pinned more take I'm pinned and
he's pinned that was a bad move because
I defend or do i king e - wait where do
I move maybe here I know time is an
issue
b3 king c3 oh that was a really good
move
Oh what do I do check no this is bad
this is really bad I lost a piece I have
to fight somehow
yeah he's displaying some strong
technique this was really sad I'm
fighting for a first place I'm losing to
some guy it was not worthy of anything
he's worthy of beating me that's true
maybe whole hanger Brooke maybe not
what he's doing okay that was
unfortunate it's a long tournament I'm
still in fourth place it looks like now
I'm in fifth place I'm still within a
game of the lead this guy's was working
every single game and winning I mean
strong player
hello ticking yo who beat me when with
no B chest surgeries restarted and I
flagged little busy because I'm on tilts
graden saying I had a night to you won I
thought my night got trapped in that
line like I saw and I see one instead of
moving the team to c4 but I wasn't sure
it was complicated the Caliph
counterplay I tried to get counterplay
as hard as I could
oh this is some reverse slug which I
probably should have avoided what can I
do 85 maybe I don't know a 5 I don't
think it prevents before but ok
something is happening here
we've transposed into some kind of
London where maybe before is not
possible
ok well it's nice so it's just like a
reverse Slav type position where I know
the idea like black wants to expand him
in the center so he probably plays 95 or
not ok that's nice now black just has a
good center
happy pieces maybe I should have played
a floor there but okay he can't play be
for it because there's all these pins
let's not trade anything you should
never trade pieces when you have more
space
okay so I'll play for it gain more space
maybe this they should take f6 maybe in
what play G v g5 just looks fun I'll
just play it relying on intuition and
thank you for the follow I mean this yes
italiano did I do this I guess I do that
then he for I have to move slightly
quicker okay I'll play Bishop g4 I want
to do this in this you might play 91
because he just wants to trade or not
okay happy getting my Bishop there oh he
played King h1 Knight G 1 okay we're
still avoiding trades as black has so
much space I just want to trap this
Bishop and in order to save it he's
gonna have to weaken himself he's gonna
have to play like h3 or h4 I don't know
if I can exploit this right away
well let's just throw pieces at him on
the Kings side not that five coming at
some point I might play Bishop d6 just
to trade off his one like good defender
but in the meantime I just want to keep
pushing like g4 with them with a pawn
storm hmm I see one King d1o rook to you
- King - - I didn't see Knight a - I
just assumed my knight was running out
of squares but I think that game should
still be worse there so I want to take
on pistol on Queen take b3 ok situations
like that and you can't calculate use
captain use intuition
so we're trading a pair of Bishops
because I just want to make him have
less defenders and then when we trade or
even if they go in trade I want to play
G for as soon as I can
cuz I'm files will open I'm hopefully
good things will happen okay he's going
for counter play Oh Tay maybe D yeah
that looks interesting some tax revision
against the Queen
threatening d3 he probably has to take
if I take with night he plays Queen d1
Queen d6 checking h1 and looking for
wins that seems very close to winning
maybe III first you take c3 might take
you three
I went some material but I don't want to
lose initiative well he's just scared
okay I'm gonna play e3 if I win material
it should be it should at least be
clearly better for black oh that's a
free night expecting between take t 2
and then 94 or that okay some annoyances
take take take mmm okay will defend my
d5 couldn't be painful but 95 Queen take
d4 okay should be okay
okay can't complain
I have 28 seconds left but he's below
two minutes and there might be tactics
against stuff kingi one is when we move
i'm throwin f6 when i can chase away the
Knights 23 seconds no I have no
discoveries no great discoveries against
the Queen yet I'm gonna push the pawn
okay that's a good sign you try and get
the H file you have seven probably not a
great move I want to get the rotate this
looks really weird let's do that cuz 92
is a threat sometimes you might trade
rooks also attacking his rook on d1 so
he's allowing 90 - whoa what's going on
okay I'm freaking out I have 10 seconds
left
when g4 with check wait did I just
plunder everything I don't know what I'm
doing this is really bad
okay time to remove okay good thing he
took like pawn there lots of removing no
he wins my queen no okay he didn't see
us I'm trying to flag him yes I flagged
him okay I played for a win there was
one second left
I could have sacked the Queen for the
pawn but he had low enough time in order
to uh Dragon okay Oh remember secret
tactics okay I'll share the secrets in
this tournament listening to all the
device will blundering pieces chess okay
that's that's the nature of blitz let me
uh I'll go back I'll share the opening
secret is that the same game this is a
long game I didn't not deserve to win
that I mean he had many different ways
to win that I'm game like he should not
have allowed me to win off those pawns
like he should just take the rook like
take the rook on the end and push the
deep on but analysis forward just to
share some prep like if you play against
the Catalan and you play wait
oh this was a different game wait I
guess I forgot to show the cattle online
previously I don't that was what
exercise sparks was referring to but
because I forgot to show it let me just
show it real quick
d 5 g 3 so ray raphson variation starts
after C 5 and then one of the main lines
is like this here Castle castle and then
Queen a four-night bt7 queen takes e4
and the secret move here is b5 where it
solves all the Box problems because you
develop the bishop and you you don't
even lose appalling because after Queen
take b5 you win back the pun might be
off topic from the game I just played
but there we go I'm gonna play one more
game and then I'll see where that takes
me in third place
[Music]
I might have to end shortly but we'll
see okay yeah I have to end very shortly
actually last game consuming the game
starts soon it's crap Mik still playing
oh he's still playing wow what's going
on in this position crime max winning
right oh he's down the exchange I have
no idea what's going on in that position
uh I'm gonna loser I'm gonna try and end
with a bang
even though this guy is 2,200 and Gary
toe Paulo freeborn's interesting name
okay it's a London
oh it's another like copycat variation I
had this earlier and I worked out really
nicely
this time i'ma plated to quicker night a
six is interesting why do I feel like I
can take with the rook on d6 let's do
that because I think Lenderman did it
once and it worked out for him it looks
completely absurd but I'm trying to end
with a bang maybe it was the wrong
decision but the minor pieces for white
are good in this position assuming he
can play e5 because all women pawns and
stuff on the Queen side
b8 square is off-limits he might play
might be eight or that yeah this is
probably just unsound I can get a Knight
to a5 somehow like king c2 and then 92
93 95 its paipa position I can play
relatively quickly problem is he's
defending everything but at least
there's pressure we move the rook back I
don't know what to do here actually
maybe this and take with pawn that's
already looking actually no he doesn't
have worked yet if he doesn't have work
be eight it's completely fine for whites
maybe I'm gonna bring the rook back to
keep the pressure probably put the King
on d3 and over defending this I might
have to do something with the nice
restrict his Knights maybe play h4 next
let me go for this move so I'm realizing
96 Ponte p6 he can't stock b7 in most
cases it's a weird idea I have triple
pawns now but I take on b8
so I don't think he saw or maybe he did
see this should be better for whites
because I have I have pawns he wins g2
but now I have check play b7 and then
Knight c5 and I don't think his might
gets back in time so he's gonna go for
counter play on the kingside but it's
gonna be too slow because this Mike
can't move anywhere actually is he could
move to e2 but then here and then if he
moves back okay that was nice
oh that was actually fun I was a cool
kind of objectively like rook Tiggy six
I'll just stockfish think of it the sock
visually looks down upon exchange sex
rope take a six I mean so I fish it
first we'll say it's better for luck
maybe I don't know maybe it is just
better for black because I couldn't take
on a six right away because my Knights
he knew and he defended but I think it
was easier to play for whites real quick
I do want to show what inspired me to
play that move if I can remember the
line because it was from the black side
in the London where white played the
slang and then Locke was Alex Slenderman
and they went into this kind of very
similar structure almost identically
reversed and white played 93 and then
Lenderman took on a three weights maybe
it's not this exact position I thought
there was a lender in game could be a
slightly different line might be -
what's
Bishop e2 maybe mr. at five no I forget
I remember a Lenderman game well maybe
it was about five first but mine might
be five wait 9h for looking for a rook
take a three no no take a three now I
forget
sadly wait can I pause the tournaments I
want to pause I don't want to start a
new game
sadly I'm in second place I have to
pause I have to go I've stuff to do
today I can't be playing chess the whole
day thank you everyone for watching and
being interesting in the chats for those
who were in the chats okay I don't think
I missed anything - meaningful but I do
appreciate the viewers I'll be back in
the future
bye guys and have a good day or good
nights or a good Bishop